simplement là encore on recommence une
commission mix paritaire à 10h30 10h30
c'est euh le début
euh de la réunion des groupes moi ce
matin j'irai chercher un mandat auprès
de mon groupe je n'irai pas à la CMP
j'estime que ma place c'est devant mon
groupe pour le présider pour expliquer
les choses et pour recevoir de la part
des sénateurs LR un mandat clair ça
n'est pas seulement Bruno rotaillot
voilà euh qui négocie tel ou tel point
je veux moi puisque ça vous a pas
échappé on a une dimension d'équipe une
dimension collective qui est très forte
voilà cette dimension je la respecte
donc je ne ferai rien qui soit en
contradiction avec ce que veut mon
groupe je serai devant mon groupe et je
ne serai pas la commissionparitaire mais
du coup est-ce qu'il faut la décaler
est-ce que 10h3 c'est pas la bonne heure
en tout en tout cas il est hors de
question de voir cet article qui est
l'article 1N qui est le premier article
qui doit tomber dans l'ordre du jour de
la commission mais vous êtes président
du groupe est-ce que cette CMP reprendre
sans vous ah non mais la CMP elle peut
elle peut faire beaucoup de choses
simplement euh ce que je Mo ce que je
demande puisque ce sont les réunions de
groupe c'est important dans la vie d'un
d'un parlement les réunions de groupe
c'est ce qui donne le là c'est ce qui
donne la ligne donc moi je veux être
relégitimé dans ce mandat de négociation
par mon groupe et donc si la commission
mixte paritaire redémarre à 10h30 elle
le peut mais elle ne doit en aucun cas
aborder un un point qui est encore une
fois
litigieux Olivier marlex dans le même
état d'esprit va faire la même chose de
son côté auprès des députés LR Olivier
marlex est pas dans la même situation
puisqu'il n'est pas dans la commission
ex paritaire j'y suis et si j'ai tenu à
y être c'est bien parce que j'avais
quelques méfiance mais ça veut dire que
vous allez forcément la CMP n'aboutira
pas si elle aboutit avant que vous soyez
revenu puisque on imagine que les deux
autres sénateurs ne voteront pas si vous
êtes absent il y a un vote qui était
prévu au Sénat à 14h30 en cas de CMP
conclusive est-ce qu'il pourra se tenir
à 7h mais bien sûr que
non